[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur le
plateau de face aux territoires sur
tv5monde en direct bien sûr mais
également en direct sur les sites de nos
producteurs partenaires ouest france
avec ouest france.fr nice matin avec
nicematin.com et franceantilles.fr avec
un léger décalage horaire du aux fuseaux
horaires aujourd'hui mon invité ce matin
c'est elisabeth moreno bonjour bon c'est
d'être avec nous sur ce plateau vous
êtes ministre délégué auprès du premier
ministre avec des compétences
ministérielles bien pourvus puisque vous
êtes chargé de l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes de la diversité est
également de l'égalité des chances merci
d'être avec nous dans face aux
territoires vous allez être interrogés
dans un instant par nos partenaires et
éditorialistes de la presse quotidienne
régionale
une question tout de suite elisabeth
mans évoqué dans l'actualité j'écoutais
bruno le maire hier soir est ce que pour
vous la nouvelle fracture sociale ce
n'est pas au fond ce prix payé à la
pompe par un certain nombre de français
je rappelle c'est entre 60 euros et 90
euros en fonction du véhicule qu'on a
est ce que cette hausse des carburants
au fond et pas une énorme inégalités
entre ceux qui peuvent se payer c'est
plein là et ce qu'ils ne peuvent plus
mais c'est justement la raison pour
laquelle bruno le maire a commencé à
proposer des solutions parce
qu'évidemment lorsque vous habitez par
exemple dans une zone rurale que vous
avez des soucis de transport de mobilité
et et que le prix du gasoil à la pompe
est aussi élevé je tiens quand même à
rappeler que ça n'est pas que l'état qui
qui est responsable de cela d'ailleurs
ce n'est pas l'état qui est responsable
de cela évidemment que nous devons
oeuvrer et trouver des solutions pour
aider les personnes qui en ont le plus
besoin et nous avons déjà commencé à le
faire et je pense que les socios
solutions qui vont être proposées vont
aider ces personnes qui sont justement
les plus éloignées et les plus en
situation de difficulté ou les plus
vulnérables quand vous faites des
déplacements ministériels partout en
france on vous en parle de ce problème
est ce que est ce que le gouvernement au
fond l'a vu arriver là anticipait
pourquoi se pose cette question parce
que on a bien entendu tous en mémoire
les gilet jaune
cette problématique qui est venu
d'ailleurs au fond aussi de la presse
quotidienne régionale qui avait remonté
ses préoccupations dans les courriers
des lecteurs des gens qui n'arrivaient
plus au fond à boucler leurs fins de
mois est-ce que c'est des choses que
vous avez un petit peu anticipé que vous
avez vu arriver ou pas du tout je crois
qu' aucun pays au monde parce que tous
les pays souffrent aujourd'hui de cette
flambée du prix du pétrole qui n'était
absolument pas prévu je ne pense pas
qu'on puisse le comparer à la crise des
gilet jaune parce que la crise et gilet
jaune c'était un sujet franco français
quand vous regardez le prix de l'énergie
aujourd'hui c'est un problème mondial et
les français peuvent le comprendre ça
est ce que vous pensez que la pédagogie
a été fait dans ce sens moi j'ai
beaucoup de confiance dans
l'intelligence des français et on
devrait pas sous-estimer leur capacité à
comprendre ces sujets là quand on prend
le temps de bien l'expliquer et c'est ce
à quoi nous oeuvrons depuis plusieurs
semaines maintenant mais il s'agit pas
d'expliquer seulement il faut aussi
proposer des solutions jean castex notre
premier ministre a commencé à le faire
nous avons énormément discuté avec les
parlementaires pour trouver des
solutions complémentaires bruno le maire
en a proposé hier et je pense que nous
allons continuer là-dessus parce que
s'il ya une chose que nous pouvons pas
accepter c'est que certains français
restent sur le bord de la route c'est le
cas de le dire parce que ils n'ont pas
les moyens de pouvoir mettre de
l'essence dans leur voiture et ça c'est
un sujet qui nous préoccupe éminemment c
et lisbeth moreno ministre délégué pour
l'égalité entre les hommes et les femmes
pour la diversité et l'égalité des
chances qui est notre invité politique
ce matin d'en face aux territoires dans
un instant françois-xavier lefranc
rédacteur en chef de ouest-france notre
partenaire et sur ce plateau pour vous
interroger elisabeth moi no mercy
[Musique]
bonjour françois xavier le franc vous
êtes jeu rédacteur en chef du plus grand
quotidien en langue française du monde
et vous êtes le rédacteur en chef dont
de ouest france bonjour madame quand on
regarde la carte des territoires
français sans oublier évidemment les
plus éloignés de paris je pense aux
territoires ultramarins on nous regarde
beaucoup là bas je pense aux
illégalement on voit aussi une carte qui
montre beaucoup d'inégalités en matière
de mobilité vous l'avez évoqué tout à
l'heure en matière de santé d'accès à la
santé en matière de numérique voilà
alors pour réduire ces inégalités est ce
que ce ne serait pas finalement des
régions renforcée qui serait des plus
efficaces est ce que le centralisme
français peut saisir la subtilité
des territoires vous savez moi je suis
né sur une île donc je sais que la
france ne serait pas la france sur ces
territoires ultramarins et je me déplace
énormément dans les zones rurales et je
vois bien que les personnes qui se
plaignent de ne pas avoir accès à
certains services de santé de ne pas
avoir accès jeu nous avons aujourd'hui
un sujet éminemment important qu'ils
aient les violences faites aux femmes
dont ne nous étions jamais emparé avec
autant de volonté que nous et nous
allons en parler le fait d'avoir la
possibilité pour les personnes qui sont
victimes de violences de déposer plainte
dans les hôpitaux et ce genre de choses
c'est éminemment important nous savons
qu'il ya certains endroits en france où
il n'y a pas de possibilité d'accéder à
tous les services de l'état de la bonne
manière c'est pour ça que nous avons mis
en place des maisons france services par
exemple une c'est pour ça que nous
sommes olivier ferrand est en train de
travailler à déployer davantage de
services de santé des médecins je suis
d'accord avec vous il y à des
territoires aujourd'hui qu'ils sont
moins pourvues en termes
d'accompagnement et dead que d'autres et
je peux vous dire que jean castex il n'y
a pas une seule semaine au conseil des
ministres où il ne demande pas à chaque
ministre que toutes les politiques
publiques que nous menions se déploie
sur l'ensemble du terrible des régions
plus puissants parce que ce serait pas
encore plus efficace ben moi je trouve
que les régions sont déjà puissante vous
avez quand je prends les je sais que
nous allons en parler mais quand je
prends les questions de violence faite
aux femmes quand je vois que nous avons
ouvert quasiment autant de places
d'hébergement de centres de prise en
charge des auteurs de violence sur les
toits territoires ultramarins dans les
zones rurales que dans les grandes
villes je me dis que nous faisons ce
qu'il faut et ce qu'il faut que nous
travaillons davantage avec les régions
que nous soyons davantage coordonner
pour être plus efficace sur le terrain
ça très certainement questions autour du
numérique c'est un sujet que vous
connaissez bien vous êtes une
spécialiste du sujet est-ce qu'il est
acceptable qui encore aujourd'hui en
france autant de zones blanches non ça
n'est pas acceptable vous savez moi
quand j'ai commencé à travailler dans le
numérique vous l'avez dit j'ai commencé
il ya 20 ans à travailler dans le
numérique au début du numérique j'étais
convaincu que c'était un sujet qui
pouvait limiter les inégalités qui
pouvait permettre à des personnes
éloignées de tout de pouvoir faire des
choses auxquelles elles n'avaient pas
accès et au fil du temps je me suis
rendu compte qu'il y avait des personnes
qui ne pouvaient pas s'acheter un
ordinateur
je me suis rendu compte qu'il y avait
des personnes qui ne savaient même pas
comment utiliser un ordinateur je pense
vraiment que lille etc trop nisme
d'aujourd'hui c'est l'illettrisme du 21e
siècle véritablement et c'est pour cela
qu'avec cedrico avec nadia et nous avons
lancé un programme nous avons investi 10
millions d'euros pour pouvoir permettre
aux personnes qui sont les plus éloignés
de ses services numériques les personnes
qui sont les plus défavorisés et bien de
se former d'avoir accès au matériel
j'étais avec olivia grégoire il ya
quelques temps chez emmaüs connect ou
avec sfr alliance nous nous rapprochons
au plus près des personnes qui sont
éloignés qu'ils ne savent pas comment
utiliser un ordinateur qui ne savent pas
c'est important que nous soyons avec les
associations et les entreprises engagées
dans cette bataille contre lille
electronista et bien justement elisabeth
moreno romain rue speed tv 78 une des
télévisions locales partenaires de cette
émission a rencontré karine emery elle
est directrice générale de mutuelles lmp
et elle a une question à vous poser
concernant cette fracture sociale pour
les personnes âgées ont les couilles
madame la ministre je souhaiterais vous
parler aujourd'hui de l'électro nisme
qui est donc un fléau qui s'accentue au
fil des années et qui touche
particulièrement les tranches de
population plus âgée donc c'est une
véritable fracture sociale qui s'opère
il s'agit de l'incapacité pour eux à
utiliser correctement les outils
numériques qui sont à leur disposition
donc dans ce qualité de mutuelles santé
nous développons des accompagnements
pour pour nos adhérents et je
souhaiterais savoir ce que vous comptez
faire pour réduire cette inégalité
sociale et cette fracture sociale qui
s'accentue mais d'abord pour cette
catégorie de population évidemment qui
est encore peut-être moins connectés oui
elle a raison de souligner qu' il n'y a
pas une seule fracture numérique il y a
des fractures numériques parce que en
fait selon votre âge et elle parle ici
des personnes âgées selon l'endroit où
vous habitez sur le territoire sur lons
la classe sociale dans laquelle vous
êtes il faut savoir que plus de 50% des
métiers du numérique par exemple sont
dans les grandes villes diversidad a
fait une étude il ya pas longtemps on a
que 30 % des femmes aujourd'hui qui sont
dans les métiers du numérique alors même
qu'on sait que un job sur trois qui sera
créé dans les cinq prochaines années
aura une composante numérique et quand
je dis ça ça veut dire que le numérique
aujourd'hui et dans la santé il est dans
l'éducation il est dans tous les axes et
comme il y à certains endroits où
parfois on a on n'a pas enfin vous voyez
qu'il ya une dématérialisation de plus
en plus importante des services de
l'état et d'autres services les
personnes âgées qui sont déjà isolé se
sentent encore plus isolé justement
est-ce que la dématérialisation accéléré
d'administration ne favorise pas aussi
le non recours au droit c'est-à-dire des
gens ne pouvant pas accéder à
l'administration parce que c'est
compliqué vont renoncer à l'ordre vous
avez raison et c'est la raison pour
laquelle je pense que cette
dématérialisation elle est importante
parce qu'il ya des personnes ont parlé
notamment des personnes âgées il y en a
qui ne peuvent pas se déplacer eh bien
ces personnes là il faut leur donner les
moyens de rester connecté à la vie si je
puis dire de pouvoir accéder à tous les
services de l'état à distance mais il
faut l'accompagner il ne s'agit pas
simplement d'eux des matières et
dématérialisés il faut que tout ce que
nous gagnons en ressources humaines en
dématérialisant il faut que nous
puissions accompagner toutes les
personnes qui en ont le plus besoin les
personnes âgées y compris les jeunes
parce que c'est pas parce que vous avez
un téléphone entre vos mains que vous
savez l'utiliser parfaitement moi je
suis en permanence confrontés aux cyber
harcèlement parce que les violences
sexistes et sexuelles ce
se propage aussi sur les réseaux si vous
aussi vous voulez le numérique s'est
déployée de manière exponentielle dans
notre société mais nous n'avons pas pris
le temps d'apprendre à nos jeunes à
l'utiliser d'apprendre à nos moins
jeunes à lui manque de la zelda goji ce
que je crois qu'ils manquent de la
pédagogie et c'est pour ça que cédric au
travail d'arrache-pied non seulement
pour que les outils fonctionnent partout
pour qu'il n'y a pas de zones blanches
mais qu'en plus on sache utiliser ces
matériels et en tirer le meilleur et
donc ça s'éteint c'est un sujet sur
lequel le gouvernement est pleinement
mobilisée aujourd'hui alors on va parler
des jeunes aussi samuel nohra de ouest
france françois xavier le franc a
rencontré jessica qui travaillent dans
la gestion de patrimoine elle cherche
des stagiaires des jeunes stagiaires ils
entendent pas on écoute on travaille
dans la gestion de patrimoine et je
m'aperçois qu'il est toujours difficile
de trouver des stagiaires de tous de
toutes origines en effet j'ai
l'impression que les stagiaires issus de
milieux plus favorisés ont plus de
confiance plus de réseau plus les codes
justement pour trouver un stage dans une
entreprise et c'est là monde peut-être
justement comme talents et compétences
pour les jeunes stagiaires issus de
milieux défavorisés
est-ce que là nous prête à faire quelque
chose pour ça que j'ai beaucoup de
jeunes stagiaires issus de milieux
défavorisés ne trouvent pas de stage
quand on connaît pas c'est pas à qui
s'adresser c'est ça c'est une véritable
inégalité et je vous pose la question
sans ignorer votre parcours personnel
qui force le respecte mais comment on
peut faire pour que ces jeunes la com
com comme le demande cette dame puisse
cet événement concret la question 2006 à
jonas pas quoi je n'en trouve pas je
veux vraiment remercier jessica pour
cette question parce que vous l'avez dit
monsieur lefranc moi j'ai grandi dans
des quartiers très défavorisé et le
problème de ces stages c'est que les
jeunes sont en permanence dans
l'autocensure ou alors ils ne savent
même pas où à quelle porte frapper c'est
ça le véritable problème qu'est ce qui
fait que les jeunes issus des quartiers
défavorisés ne réussissent pas c'est pas
parce qu'il manque de volonté c'est pas
parce qu'il manque de talent c'est pas
parce qu'il manque dans vie c'est parce
qu'il ya un ils ne savent pas à quelle
porte frapper 2 ils sont dans l'auto
censure parce qu'ils sont convaincus que
ça n'est pas pour eux et 3 les
entreprises ne leur tente pas les bras
comme elle devrait faire moi j'ai été
dirigeant d'entreprise pendant de
nombreuses années les stages très
souvent se partager entre les
collaborateurs de l'entreprise qu'est ce
que j'ai fait à un moment donné j'ai dit
on va mettre un pourcentage de ces
stages à destination de ces jeunes et il
y à des entreprises que je salue
aujourd'hui qui justement font un
travail colossal sur le terrain pour
aller chercher ces jeunes et je pense
notamment à angie que j'ai rencontré il
n'ya pas longtemps je pense à france
télécom que j'ai rencontrés hier il y à
des associations comme diversidad des
associations comme les déterminer qui
aide ces jeunes et il ya une plate forme
au sein de l'état qui permet aux jeunes
d'aller trouver les stages disponible
mais s'il ya des jeunes déjà ces jeunes
que j' étais quand j'étais jeune et bien
je veux leur dire que la première forme
la première chose à faire c'est de
pousser les portes d'aller chercher les
longs cils jeunes et des moins jeunes
qui ne trouvent pas de place du fait de
leur identité de leur nom et de leur
prénom c'est inacceptable le cv anonyme
l'épilation vous avez raison de
souligner monsieur le franc que la
discrimination à l'emploi est la
première et discrimination dans notre
pays il ya 25 critères de discrimination
prohibés dans la loi française et la
discrimination à l'emploi et celle qui
arrive toujours en tête c'est le
syndrome mohamed c'est le syndrome
mohamed c'est le syndrome du 9 3 et wii
le cv anonyme peut être une solution moi
j'ai été chef d'entreprise et je sais
que ça peut faire peur aux chefs
d'entreprises de se dire mon dieu je
vais recruter quelqu'un que je n'ai pas
vu que je n'ai pas rencontré mais si
vous recrutez une personne sur ses
compétences sur ses talents et je
rappelle que les compétences le talent
et le savoir-faire n'ont ni couleur de
peau ni origine sociale ni genre ni
identité sexuelle et bien si vous donner
la chance à une personne de vous prouver
ses compétences et ses capacités vous
n'aurez pas de problème de recrutement
cet après midi pardonnez moi je termine
là dessus cet après midi je reçois au
ministère les agences intérim qui ont
été épinglés par sos racisme dans
intestines qui a été fait récemment dans
le secteur du bâtiment certaines
entreprises certaines entreprises
demandent à ne recruter que des
personnes européenne comment peut-on
dans un secteur aussi en tension que le
bâtiment discriminer je rappelle quand
même que c'est prohibé par la loi que
c'est puni par la loi comment est-ce
qu'on peut encore faire ce genre de
choses je pense qu'il faut être
intransigeant sur la loi qu'il faut
sanctionner lorsque ce genre de choses
arrive et je vais voir avec ces agences
intérim quelle mesure elles vont mettre
en place pour arrêter de discriminer
l'égalité femmes-hommes c'est aussi la
question du congé de paternité 28 jours
on a l'impression que certains n'osent
pas encore prendre leur congé paternité
rapidement mais comment on peut faire
pour accélérer sa je pense que les
jeunes générations ne se pose pas de
question j'ai rencontré une jeune femme
de 35 ans hier qui vient d'avoir son
enfant et qui me dit vous ne pouvez pas
imaginer combien ça a changé ma vie le
fait que mon conjoint soit avec moi mais
on en 14 jours c'est essentiel c'est
quelque chose qui vient de commencer
beaucoup de gouvernements avaient parlé
de ceux du doublement de ce congé
paternité je suis extrêmement heureuse
que nous l'ayons mis en place parce que
c'est bien non seulement pour l'enfant
c'est bien pour la maman mais c'est bien
aussi pour le papa donc vous savez il ya
des choses qui prennent du temps à se
mettre en route mais la marche est
lancée en tout cas c'est elisabeth
moreno à la ministre déléguée chargée de
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
la diversité l'égalité des chances qui
est notre invité politique ce matin on a
une tradition dans cette émission un
collaborateur de ouest-france
dessinateur un peu éditorialiste du coup
chaunu à une question sous forme de
dessin à vous poser il s'agit de miss
france regardez
madame la ministre bon le thème de ma
question va vous paraître futile quoique
le 11 décembre aura lieu au pays où
coulent le lait la crème le cidre
l'élection de miss france à caen en
normandie l'association osez le
féminisme
met en cause les critères de recrutement
à l'élection de miss france alors la
question que je vous pose et s'il vous
plaît ne me fait pas une réponse de
normand est la suivante oui
miss france véhicule une image positive
de la femme moderne
non miss france est juste un moyen pour
les marchands du temple de faire leur
beurre
sur le dos de la femme
on vous enverra le dessin je trouve que
le dessin est magnifique moi je pense
que miss france fait partie de nos
traductions de nos traditions de notre
culture est ce qui me ce qui m'interroge
ce sont les règles que je trouve
complètement avez-vous pouvait peser sur
ses régulières d'amis dit rappelle moi
je vais l'écouter elle je lance un appel
à miss france pourquoi est-ce qu'une
miss france ne peut pas faire d'ironie
pourquoi une miss france ne peut pas
faire d'ironie pourquoi est-ce qu'une
miss france une candidate à miss france
qui pose les seins nus pour lutter
contre les cancers du sein est exclu
pourquoi est-ce qu'une miss france ne
pourrait pas être une maman je trouve
que les règles sont complètement has
been et il est grand temps qu'elle
change c'est bien le message va passer
un auprès du comité miss france la une
de ouest france françois xavier le franc
pour terminer avec vous oui la question
des voitures d'occasion et un éditorial
sur la question polonaise au sein de
l'union européenne ce n'est pas une
petite question merci françois xavier le
franc dans un instant patrice maggio de
nice matin est avec nous
[Musique]
bonjour patrice maggio vous êtes le
directeur des rédactions de
li ce matin donc var matin également
merci d'être avec nous sur ce plateau
dans un instant vous avez la parole mais
on va écouter cyril bouttier qui est
dans le même groupe que vous directeur
des rédactions de france antilles qu'à
une question à poser à elisabeth moreno
ou écoute bonjour madame la ministre il
ya quelques mois dans les colonnes de
nos journaux france antilles et france
guyane vous évoquiez les 46 mesures du
grenelle des violences conjugales est ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous pouvez nous faire un
premier bilan des mesures mises en place
pour nos territoires des territoires où
la question des violences conjugales
revient très fréquemment et madame l'ami
je précise ce chiffre qui m'a été donnée
par cécile fournier la chef d'édition de
cette émission 25 % + 25 % de violences
conjugales en martinique en 2010 est par
exemple oui il faut savoir du jeu sur
les territoires ultramarins les
violences sont aussi présente que sur
l'ensemble du territoire la différence
sur les territoires ultramarins c'est
que il y a une forme de promiscuité tout
le monde se connaît la honte et
l'emprise et la peur sont encore plus
importantes qu'ailleurs la mobilité est
beaucoup plus difficile et c'est pour ça
que nous avons mis énormément d'efforts
sur les différents dispositifs qui ont
été mis en place dans le cadre du
grenelle des violences conjugales pour
vous donner une idée on a ouvert 10 %
parce que on a augmenté de 60 % le
nombre de places d'hébergement pour
accueillir les victimes de violences et
sur les territoires ultramarins j'ai
fait attention à ce qu on en ouvre 10%
on a ouvert des centres de prise en
charge des auteurs de violences
conjugales parce que si on ne lutte pas
contre la récidive eh bien ces violences
continueront de se perpétrer eh bien
nous avons cinq centres de prise en
charge des auteurs de violence sur les
territoires ultramarins on a aussi
décidé d'avoir des référents au sein des
commissariats et des gendarmeries sur
tout le territoire français dans
l'hexagone et sur les territoires
ultramarins et on en à si je me souviens
bien 14 qui ont été recrutés et
nouvellement donc je veux vraiment
répondre à votre question en vous disant
qu' aucune des mesures que je prends
aussi mon ministère n'oublie les
territoires ultramarins parce que je
sais combien ce fléau est important
là-bas ils font partie de face aux
territoires bien sûr patrice maggio
directeur adjoint de la rédaction de
nice matin même le ministre bonjour
l'égalité hommes-femmes c'est
effectivement la grande cause du
quinquennat lancé il ya presque quatre
ans avec de grandes ambitions avec un
dispositif détaillé c'est vrai quand en
2016 les chiffres étaient terribles avec
123 femmes tuées par leur partenaire ou
ex partenaire mais l'an dernier c'était
encore 102 un chiffre encore
épouvantable et pendant le 2ème
confinement les violences conjugales les
signalements de violences conjugales ont
augmenté de
62% c'est presque l'heure du bilan vous
le trouvez comment ce bilan moi je
trouve que ya plusieurs choses par
rapport à ça monsieur maggio la première
chose que je voudrais dire c'est que
pendant très longtemps les violences
conjugales ont été ensevelis sous un à
soi sous de l'indifférence soit sous de
la honte soit sous de la peur etc etc
c'était cool il avait rejeté clic et
c'est culturel culturel c'est vraiment
culturel parce que vous voyez il n'y a
pas un seul pays au monde aujourd'hui
qu'ils puissent réellement dire que les
femmes sont traitées comme les hommes
les violences intrafamiliales sont là
les violences conjugales sont là les
viols sont là les violences économiques
sont présente donc aujourd'hui partout
dans le monde les femmes sont souvent
considérées comme des citoyennes de
seconde zone je peux vous dire que les
évidemment les associations féministes
avaient énormément travaillé sur ces
questions mais c'est depuis 2010 est que
le président de la république a décidé
de faire de l'égalité entre les femmes
et les hommes la grande cause du
quinquennat que nous avons accéléré le
processus pour protéger les femmes
victimes de violence et c'est un vrai
fléau culturelle dans notre pays que
c'est un grenelle parce que marcher
plusieurs choses grenelle des violences
conjugales lancé par marlène schiappa et
le premier ministre de l'époque 46
mesures qui sont prises parmi ses 46
mesure les bracelets anti rapprochement
qui n'existait pas depuis le mois de
décembre 2020 ils sont la technologie en
service la technologie au service 2
benoît de exactement pour protéger les
victimes les téléphones grave danger
vous êtes une femme victime de violences
conjugales vous avez déposé plainte les
policiers ou les gendarmes vous remettre
un téléphone
je le décide vous remettre un téléphone
que vous appelez et qui sont connectés
directement aux fables à l'impossible il
jette moreno cas d'abus possibles c'est
à dire c'est r d de trop d'appels trop
de vous êtes bien jugulés ça comment
comment trouver ma ba de la bonne mesure
c'est mal connaître les victimes de
violences conjugales que de dire qu'il
peut y avoir des abus aucune femme ne va
appeler les policiers ou les gendarmes
pour leur dire je suis victime de
violence si elles ne sont pas victimes
de violences il est grand temps qu'on ne
met plus en doute les paroles des femmes
qui sont vous devriez de vie allant même
jusqu'à 1er mai mais et c est encore
présent il y a les policiers les
gendarmes la plupart des policiers et
des gendarmes font un travail
remarquable
ce sont des requérants bien formellement
important bien formés ce sont des
et ce sont les premiers remparts face à
ces violences aujourd'hui nous avons 90
mille policiers et gendarmes qui ont été
formés à la prise en considération des
plaintes est ce qu'il faut continuer
d'aller plus loin oui il faut continuer
de faire vous avez entendu parler de ce
hashtag double peine qui dit que
certains policiers ou gendarmes ne
prennent pas suffisamment en
considération la plainte des victimes
j'ai rencontré les avocates absolument
j'ai rencontré les avocats qui ont lancé
cette tribune et je comprends la
problématique et nous continuons de
travailler mais il ne faut quand même
pas oublier que les policiers et les
gendarmes sont les premiers remparts de
ces violences et puis pour juste pour
terminer là dessus on a augmenté de 60 %
le nombre de places d'hébergement on a à
améliorer la coordination sur le terrain
parce que vous pouvez mettre toutes les
actions au niveau national si sur le
terrain les personnes ne travaillent pas
davantage ensemble et de manière plus
efficace on aura encore des situations
comme mérignac comme mérignac ou hayange
donc je crois qu'il est vraiment
important de reconnaître ne serait ce
que pour les victimes de reconnaître que
les actions qui ont été mises en place
aujourd'hui fonctionne mais on part de
tellement loin que ça met trop de temps
chaque féminicide reste un féminicide et
c'est toute la société qui doit se
saisir de ces questions les associations
l'état les collectivités locales et
territoriales les maires par exemple
puisqu'on parle des territoires mais
aussi les associations et les
entreprises on reste sur les violences
faites aux femmes et dans ce cas là
malgré tout les 10 positifs y ont été
évoquées est lancé on voit bien que les
chiffres restent terribles est-ce qu'il
ya d'autres mesures qui sont dans les
tuyaux pour tendre vers le chiffre zéro
qui ne peut être que le seul objectif
possible alors déjà vous avez dit tout à
l'heure que pour la première fois
l'année dernière le chiffre est baissé à
102 même si un féminicide reste un
féminicide de trop mais depuis qu on
compte le nombre de femmes qui meurent
sous les coups de leur conjoint eh bien
nous sommes arrivés à 102 il faut
continuer de travailler et gérald
darmanin quand il dit qu'il va faire en
sorte que les plaintes des victimes
soient traitées en priorité c'est une
mesure supplémentaire quand eric
dupond-moretti décide d'utiliser là
aussi les technologies pour faire en
sorte que les auteurs se met à la place
de leurs victimes et qu'ils comprennent
la souffrance des enfants qui jusque là
n'avait pas suffisamment été pris en
considération et là aussi adrien taquet
fait un travail colossal pour protéger
les enfants victimes de violences au
sein de leur famille qui eux aussi
d'ailleurs peuvent devenir des
agresseurs tellement ils sont
traumatisés par tous ces drames et bien
moi je pense que le travail est en route
que beaucoup de choses ont été faites
mais qu'il ne faut pas se relâcher parce
qu'il rend ce il reste encore énormément
de choses à faire alors denis carot
qu'est le directeur des rédactions du
groupe nice matin une question à vous
poser on va passer au thème de la
méritocratie
bonjour elisabeth moreno vous étiez à
nice vendredi aux entretiens de nice
organisé par le groupe nice matin vous
avez évoqué l'exaspération et la
résignation d'un certain nombre de
français il faut dire que beaucoup sont
encore touchées par ce qu'on pourrait
appeler les inégalités de naissance
d'après une enquête de l' ocde il faut
six générations à un enfant d'ouvrier
pour parvenir au statut de cadre moyen
elisabeth moreno que pourrait-on mettre
en oeuvre pour favoriser un modèle qui
fasse la part belle au mérite six
générations 180 ans 1,70 qu'il faut pour
que les descendants d'une famille pauvre
accède aux revenus moyens cent
quatre-vingts ans et je vous laisse
imaginer
vous savez un pays qui n'a pas d'espoir
est un pays qui se meurt un pays dans
lequel sa jeunesse peut penser qu'elle
n'a aucune chance quoi qu'elle fasse
de réussir sa vie est de faire mieux que
ses parents est un pays qui ne va pas
bien la france est l'un des pays qui
redistribue le plus et en même temps on
se retrouve dans ces situations où un
enfant d'ouvrier se dit parce que 180
ans jusqu'à nouvel ordre il ne vivra pas
jusqu'à 180 ans et qui un enfant qui se
dit quoi que je fasse quels que soient
les efforts quelles que soient les
études que je fasse jamais je
n'arriverai à faire mieux que mes
parents c'est insupportable c'est
inacceptable c'est pour ça que jean
michel blanquer a fait énormément dans
le cadre de l'éducation pour améliorer
cette situation quand il dédouble les
classes de cp et de ce1 c'est pour
permettre à des enfants en situation
défavorisée dont les parents n'ont pas
forcément les moyens de les accompagner
pour pouvoir aller loin dans leurs
études de pouvoir le faire les sites et
éducatives ou encore les les repas à 1
euro tout ça c'est des solutions qui
vont permettre à ces enfants d'étudier
dans de meilleures conditions pour
pouvoir réussir parce que tout commence
avec les études les singes et on
reviendra tout à l'heure sur votre
parcours qui a quand même un peu
exceptionnel joué d'abord qu'on s'arrête
sur le budget dont vous disposez puisque
vous êtes ministre délégué auprès du
premier ministre alors vous avez des
portefeuilles très important l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes on en a
parlé la diversité l'égalité des chances
c'est vaste c'est clairement au coeur
des préoccupations des français mais
quand on regarde le projet de budget
2022 ces 50 millions d'euros certes
c'est 9 millions de plus que l'année
précédente quasiment le double depuis
2000 17 mai à l'échelle des comptes à
l'échelle des comptes de l'état c'est
pas lourd surtout que cet argent sert à
financer des dispositifs qui relève
parfois d'autres minister ma question
c'est est-ce que la lutte pour l'égalité
ce n'est pas aussi une question d'argent
monsieur mathieu jeu j'étais chef
d'entreprise avant de devenir ministre
donc je sais que l'argent c'est le nerf
de la guerre le budget de mon ministère
a doublé depuis 2010 est doublé dans un
contexte économique
sanitaires extrêmement complexe on aura
souvent lorsque les gens parlent de mon
budget il ne parle que de ce budget dupé
137 qui est le budget destiné à
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
mais quand olivier véran investi 5
millions d'euros pour que les femmes
puissent déposer plainte dans les
hôpitaux quand jean michel blanquer
décide que les vingt mille professeurs
et enseignants vont avoir une formation
à la culture à l'égalité quand
emmanuelle wargon investi 10 millions
d'euros pour qu'on augmente les places
d'hébergement et les services qui
accompagnent les victimes de violence
tous et ce budget là ne sont pas pris en
compte dans mon ministère et pourtant
vous dans la maîtrise et la question de
poterie badges aux est-ce que vous en
avez la maîtrise tout mais moi je
traverse en administration c'est plus
compliqué alors d'abord j'ai une
administration sur les questions
d'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
est ensuite sur les questions d'égalité
des chances qui sont quand même le fil
rouge du quinquennat d'emmanuel macron
et bien vous imaginez bien que ce n'est
pas qu'au sein d'un ministère dont nous
pouvons nous en emparer quand elisabeth
bornes met en place le programme un
jeune une solution c'est bien pour
lutter contre ce déterminisme social et
faire en sorte qu'aucun jeune n'est pas
un stage n'est pas une formation n'est
pas un emploi donc il faut regarder ces
sujets là dans sa globalité parce que de
la même manière que tous ces sujets sont
complètement trans partisan ils sont
également interministériel et c'est tout
le budget du gouvernement qu on devrait
regarder dont on devrait regarder
l'investissement pendant 20 minutes à
jouer et vous faites une lune plus
formidable pour vos collègues du
gouvernement rapidement votre parcours
dans la vie quand je disais qu'il était
exceptionnel vous êtes né donc au cap
vert au large du sénégal dans une petite
île voilà vous avez un parcours
quasiment ascensionnel vous êtes passés
d'un poste de dirigeant international au
gouvernement en un week-end est-ce que
vous avez souffert du racisme pendant
toutes ces années voilà oui oui j'ai
souffert de la misogynie amenant j'ai
souffert de la misogynie j'ai souffert
du racisme j'ai un handicap je coche
toutes les cases jeu dis souvent je
coche toutes les cases de l'aide de
l'impossibilité et peut-être que mon
exemple montre à toutes les femmes à
toutes les personnes en situation de
handicap à toutes les personnes à qui on
dit c'est impossible c'est pas pourquoi
reste data place que notre place c'est
celle que nous choisissons ça va mieux
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui ça va mieux
parce que je sais mieux me défendre mais
je sais que le racisme les sexisme et la
misogynie existe toujours et c'est pour
ça que je suis fier de porter ces
batailles la une de nice matin quand
vous êtes le directeur adjoint de la
rédaction donc l'accent soeur encore un
budget très important pour les français
et ça pourquoi simplement me disant bon
bah ça flambe merci patrice maggio
directeur adjoint des rédactions de
nice-matin partenaires de cette émission
dans un instant sylvia garcia tv5monde
nous rejoint pour parler de questions
internationales avec elisabeth moreno la
ministre qui est avec nous sur ce
plateau aujourd'hui je remercie monsieur
mathieu
[Musique]
voilà il se met morano ministre de
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
de la diversité et de l'égalité des
chances sylvia oui on va rentrer du
fespaco au burkina faso c'est un des
grands rendez vous culturel du continent
c'est le festival panafricain du cinéma
de la télévision de ouagadougou il est
consacré cette année aux diasporas
auquel emmanuel macron fait des clins
d'oeil pour vous c'est un c'est un
boulevard c'était pratique moi je suis
extrêmement heureuse que le président de
la république ait décidé d'ailleurs il
l'avait annoncé à ouagadougou en 2017
qu'il voulait écrire un nouveau chapitre
de l'histoire
entre le continent africain et la france
parce que vous avec le président là nous
avons résidant au burkina mais et le
président burkinabé vous avez
que nous le voulions pas que des esprits
triste le veuille ou pas il n'y a que 15
kilomètres qui séparent le continent
africain de la france sinon il y est de
2,2 l'europe et de la france nos
histoires sont liés notre culture est
lié et nos destins sont liés et que le
président de la république décide en
s'appuyant sur la jeunesse en s'appuyant
sur la société civile tout en
travaillant avec les institutions avec
les états de construire une nouvelle
histoire entre nos deux continents entre
la france et le continent africain je
trouve que c'est tout à fait bénéfique
et je me réjouis de pouvoir vous levez
vous et vous le vivez puisque vous étiez
au fespaco vous avez représenté la
france au nouveau sommet afrique france
on met revenir dans un instant aussi
tout d'abord on vous voyez avec le
président burkinabè roch marc christian
kaboré quoi avez vous parlé ce que vous
avez parlé notamment c'est pas votre
portefeuille mais des questions de
sécurité alors les questions de sécurité
c'est florence parly et jean yves le
drian donc il vous en parleront mieux
que moi ne vais pas parler cinéma avec
lui on as on a surtout parlé des jeunes
on a parlé des femmes parce que le
burkina faso en ligne en parfois mais
c'est l'un des pays qui le en afrique
l'un des premiers pays à s'être
intéressé aux violences faites aux
femmes aux violences sexistes aux
violences sexuelles enfin tout ce que
vous pouvez imaginer au fait que les
jeunes filles se marient très très jeune
et que donc elle n'a elle n'a y pas à
l'école donc tous ces sujets là le
burkina faso sont nés en paraîtrait très
vite j'ai été accueillie d'ailleurs pas
rare ministre en charge de l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes de la
famille etc on a parlé évidemment de la
situation sécuritaire parce que c'était
un souffle salutaire il faut savoir que
le fespaco c'est le programme
audiovisuel et cinématographique le plus
important d'afrique est le plus vieux
est de 50 ans il serait en afrique
quatre parcours vous emmener beaucoup en
afrique c'est votre continent d'origine
mais vous avons professionnellement vous
aimez aussi ce que vous le sentez battre
le pouls du continent le continent est
dans une dynamique extraordinaire vous
savez depuis d'ici 2050 le continent
africain aura la population active la
plus importante au monde révèle aura
dépassé les 7 jeux le salarié de la
jeunesse si vous voyez la créativité
vous savez quand vous n'avez rien vous
êtes obligé de tout inventé de toute
innover de tout créer est ce le festival
s'exporte au niveau panafricain mais
aussi au niveau international
le film que j'ai vu la veille qui
n'était pas en compétition a été
récompensé à cannes de madame diop
atlantique donc moi je salue cette
vibrante dynamique de la jeunesse sur le
continent et je crois que l'avenir du
continent repose non seulement sur sa
jeunesse mais aussi sur les femmes sur
la jeunesse qui étaient conviés donc à
ce sommet un nouveau sommet afrique
france
est ce que l'on considérait killer alors
moi je sors c'est moyennement
ça s'est plutôt bien passé très bien
mais ça c'est bien on a dit que la
prestation des manuels macron époque ça
s'est bien passé a les mêmes envies
d'aveux vie a toujours il ya ceux il se
regarde on se dit est ce que c'est pas
un peu un jeu est-ce que c'est pas une
mise en scène fait craindre une
violation kaboré par exemple qu'est-ce
qui vous a dit vous ai dit la regrettée
d'y être comment il aperçut lui ce
nouveau sommet afrique-france le
président kaboré évidemment savait que
ce sommet était en cours d'ailleurs le
maire de ouagadougou était au sommet
afrique france il sait très bien que ça
n'est pas une question de est ce que nos
relations institutionnelles vont changer
celles ci ne peuvent pas changer les
états parle aux états mais il y a un tel
french bashing sur le continent africain
qui s'élève de la région de personnes
qui célèbrent juin selon vous mais moi
je trouve que c'est injuste dans la rue
la raison je si vous voulez j'entends
les arguments mais je pense que cette
jeunesse avait aussi besoin de
comprendre ce que sont ces relations
cette jeunesse avait besoin d'entendre
qu'elle est la volonté du président de
la république emmanuel macron de
construire cette nouvelle histoire essec
nouvelle histoire nous ne pouvons pas la
construire avec le continent si nous
nous parlons pas à l'associé la snda
breizh emmanuel macron a été moins bien
perçu que précédemment dit voilà il a
parlé à l'afrique alors que l'afrique
est plurielle extra faisait entendu
c'est que l'afrique ces 54 pays tout le
monde sait que l'afrique est plurielle
mais toute l'afrique étaient représentés
lors de ce sommet vous avez déjà à
l'après than words and et moi justement
les premiers de cordée
comme vous vous êtes une première de
cordée en quoi ce nouveau sommet afrique
france représente vraiment le continent
et les sociétés civiles africaines dans
leur entier il y avait à montpellier
quatre mille personnes
jeunesse française jeunesse de la
diaspora jeunesse africaine il y avait
tous les âges présent il y avait des des
artistes il y avait des sportifs il y
avait des entrepreneurs et les les onze
jeunes qui étaient sur scène et qui
parlait à emmanuel macron ont font
partie d'un panel de cinq mille
personnes que achille mbembe qui a
conduit les dialogues les discussions de
même que le cpa wilfrid laurier no de
rigaud qui ont parlé à plus de 5000
personnes pendant trois ans pour
entendre cette jeunesse et comprendre
pourquoi il y à 7 cette forme de
détestation qui seul élève qui mieux que
le président de la république peut
parler de ce nouveau partenariat que
nous souhaitons mettre en oeuvre d'un
mot je vous a vu vous exprimer enfin ça
c'est à cet auditoire vous êtes senti
ému je me trompe j'étais extrêmement ému
je suis tellement fière de ma double
culture j'aime tellement l'afrique
j'aime tellement la france j'aime
tellement l'europe et le continent
africain et que personne ne me demande
de choisir je suis pleinement qui je
suis et nous sommes très nombreux et il
n'en déplaise à ces cassandre qui ne
veulent pas que cette relation entre le
continent africain et la france
fonctionne et bien je peux vous dire que
cette relation va fonctionner parce que
c'est une détermination que nous avons
c'est bien d'être ministre pour agir et
des vêtements reno est ce que vous on
dit ah ça est ce que vous vous imaginiez
la vie de ministre comme celles que vous
avez aujourd'hui ou pas ces gens
puissent priver vous aviez un regard
forcément très différent vous savez
quand vous allez dans l'entreprise vous
faites fonctionner une entreprise vous
proposer une offre vous proposer des
services jamais je n'ai eu la
responsabilité de vies humaines si je ne
mets pas les bonnes politiques publiques
en place pour sauver les victimes de
violences conjugales tous les deux jours
dans notre pays comme une forme presque
tous les deux jours dans notre pays une
femme meurt sous les coups de son
conjoint ou de son ex conjointe des
personnes lgbt plus sont agressés
violente et humilié je n'ai jamais eu
d'aussi belle responsabilité et en même
temps aussi complexe parce que lorsqu'il
s'agit de dignité humaine lorsqu'il
s'agit de vies humaines et bien quand
vous vous levez le matin vous savez
pourquoi vous vous levez ce n'est pas
discourtois de vous demandez vous ne
vous sentez pas une istres caution
d'emmanuel macro moment la campagne
présidentielle va s'ouvrir ou vous y
jouerez un rôle est-ce que vous est-ce
que vous ne sentez pas au fond que ce
regard peut te fais sur vous quand
j'étais dans le monde de l'entreprise et
que je suis devenu pdg on m'a dit qu'est
ce que cette fait d'être la première
femme noire a dirigé un grand groupe
international en france il faut
maintenant que je suis en ministre on me
dit est ce que t'as pas l'impression
d'être caution pourquoi est-ce que
systématiquement les femmes doivent
justifier la place qu'elles prennent je
me sens complètement à ma place que
celui qui croit que je suis une caution
le crois ça ne me regarde pas vous allez
jouer un rôle dans la campagne
présidentielle bien sûr que je défendrai
le bilan du ministère qui est le mien et
tout dépendra si le président de la
république et candidat et qu'il me le
demande évidemment que je défendrai son
bilan merci elizabeth moreno ministre
délégué auprès du premier ministre avec
des compétences larges l'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes la diversité et
l'égalité des chances d'avoir été notre
invité politique aujourd'hui d'en face
aux territoires ils sont co produite par
ouest-france et le groupe nice matin
france antilles merci sylvia garcia si
la semaine prochaine nous recevons
johanna rolland la ministre vous le
savez deux papables dans la mer la mer
devenant pardo fait penser encore merci
beaucoup au revoir à tous à la semaine
prochaine merci
[Musique]